how's it going guys um and if you
haven't heard by now I imagine you have
but if you haven't uh today or today as
I'm filming this well might be yesterday
by now by the time you see this roud the
world lost Robin Williams to depression
ultimately and it's sad and it sucks and
I don't do celebrity death videos I go
celebrity died let's talk about a kind
of thing but I did want to do a video
that that celebrated his life that kind
of showed what he gave and what he did
at least how I saw it so this is a movie
that I'm gonna review that has a Robin
Williams character that completely
encompasses how I saw Robin Williams and
why I loved him I'm gonna let you know
this right out the gate here for every
dollar of revenue this video brings into
my channel I will donate all of that
money to the anxiety and depression
Association of America so we can go
ahead and get rid of that blight on
humanity that is depression all the
money from this video all of it donated
so yeah get this video circulated around
I'll give you more details about that at
the end of this video so stick around
for the end but for now let's review
this awesome movie with one of my
favorite performances from Robin
Williams
Aladin you know this is actually creepy
but kind of real I was out and about
today I didn't know that Robin Williams
died so I was on Twitter and I was
tweeting stuff and people were like oh
Robin Williams died and the reason I
didn't know he died because I was at the
store I swear to god this is real
looking for the Aladdin soundtrack
because I just hadn't had a hankering
for it I was just like I want to hear
the Aladdin soundtrack right now so I
went out looking for it I feel like if
the universe wants me to review this
movie I should review this movie so
Aladdin was one of the Disney movies and
what I like to call the Golden Age the
hierarchy of Disney Little Mermaid
Beauty and the Beast Aladdin Lion King
that was it that was the the quad fact
reply by that's not a word well it does
not it should be and now it is because
everything was gold it was top-notch
Aladdin when I when it came out I
watched it a zillion and a half times
and I heard about the Lion King I was
like just no way it's gonna be better
than this and the Lion King was but that
doesn't take away from what Latin is
Aladdin is the story of Aladdin he's
what they call a street rat in Agrabah
you know he's these lower-class he
doesn't have a home he steals he gets a
crush on Princess Jasmine but Princess
Jasmine can't marry him she has to marry
a prince and it's pretty much classic
90s Disney it's just classic Disney
let's not mess with that for me level
let's show it in a few different ways
you have Jafar Jafar as the Sultan's
advisor and that was pretty much it's
pretty much a classic tale now oh the
advisor that's actually a really evil
guy but this is the first time I saw so
everything that had that plot point even
if it came out before Aladdin I was like
you're copying Aladdin yeah you came out
decades before but you're still copy in
Aladdin always name is Jafar see even
Prince of Persia copied a lab that you
find out Prince of Persia came out
before alive and you're like well shut
up and the movies entertaining enough
but it's when you get to the genie
that's when the movie explodes and
that's why when I was like oh a Latin
Robin Williams I decided to talk about
it right now Robin Williams as the genie
in this movie is the greatest supporting
character ever one of definitely this is
the movie that taught me that the
supporting character can steal the
entire show is the first time I ever saw
that because before that I'm like you
have main characters and you have
secondary characters supporting
characters they all know their place
Robin Williams as a genie is like no my
place is to be the biggest character on
the cover art Robin Williams so meet the
genie his role it's one of those things
where you hear reports to the fact that
he ad-libbed so much to have like 16
hours of recordings of him or that it
was a lot of hours of recordings I guess
I also read
this might be BS but I could see it
being true that he went off the script
and off the rails so much that in the
finished product they couldn't actually
submit this to the Academy for Best
Adapted Screenplay because they're like
what adaptation it's just it's not the
same that is not that so that's what I
loved about him I grew up on stories of
Robin Williams ad living on Mork & Mindy
just such a big thing about who he was I
was the ad lib King so when I say he
made the genie his he completely made
the genie his the genie is his character
and this movie has arguably the greatest
ensemble of musical numbers ever even in
the Lion King you have that can you feel
the love you're like skip I like that
song that's the song that was like the
Oscar song for the Lion King doesn't
change the fact that I like the fast
beat stuff this movie all cool fast beat
and even when it's not fast beat
it's like the quintessential Disney love
song I can open your eye maybe what
makes it cool is the fact that they're
on a magic carpet the entire time you're
like I did dream ten tenten taboos no
you're doing that's not what you're
supposed to do and the action scenes are
great too it's like when they started
integrating CGI with animation this
movie did it actually in a few different
scenes nobody's really exciting with the
magic carpets going through the Cave of
Wonders you're like this yeah it's too
cool like I had never seen something
like that in an animation before this is
a new level of exciting a new level of
entertaining this movie blew my mind at
a hundred different levels actually come
to think about it this is the only movie
that I can think of a Disney movie where
the villain doesn't have his own
full-length song this one Jafar is like
yeah I'll give you a few notes that's
ultimately the prince all these song but
changed a little bit it's one-tenth the
length you guys already know I'm evil I
don't need a song and I like the end a
lot too because the fact it will spoiler
alert imma talk about the end Jeff R
gets the lamp and then the genie has to
obey Him it's not like the genius like
oh my ideology is in line with yours and
I asked screw Aladdin granting wishes
now you can see the pain in his eyes
when he's granting Jafar's wishes he's
like Oh Howard shoots off like a rocket
and genies just like oh I betrayed her I
love it when someone good has to do bad
and they know they're doing bad then no
control over it that happened in another
recent animation and it was awesome guys
Aladdin is one of the greatest Disney
movies ever it's that Disney movie that
I look at I'm like I just want you to
recapture movies like this and The Lion
King and the Little Mermaid
I want you to make them all feel like
that the animation is great the computer
animation when they use it is great it
had a great villain it had a great
premise and it had one of the greatest
supporting characters of all time to
completely stole the movie because
Aladdin is awesome tacular and like I
said in the beginning of this video all
the adsense revenue that this video
brings into my channel I will donate to
the anxiety and depression Association
of America will call in the Ataa now cuz
that's just a long time all of it every
penny we're talking this video makes 100
bucks 5000 if this video makes 1.5
million dollars the adaa just made 1.5
million dollars in donations I hope that
that'd be awesome genuinely would
because depression is such a huge thing
that plagues a lot of people out there I
want to see it be a word that we don't
even know the definition of anymore cuz
it's so gone I don't want to see people
commit suicide from depression anymore I
just don't want that to be a thing in
the world I love laughter I love that
Robin Williams gave the world laughter
but the fact that he fell to depression
it's just kind of a personal thing to me
because depression is a big part of its
in my family and I've seen it all my
life and I've seen people with it and it
sucks it completely said there's nothing
good about it so vortex which ironically
sucks away that which Robin Williams
gave the world so in a very big way this
was a personal thing where I looked at
it when if this pillar of laughter which
was Robin Williams could follow the
depression I was like no all right let's
do something about that it's gonna be
solved overnight no is this video
single-handedly going to solve it now
it'll be one brick in a series of bricks
and you have enough bricks and you build
a dam to block out all the stupid
that stupid being depression I
believe we all want what Robin Williams
wanted which is a world without
depression with laughter and fun
vibrance and embracing life not being
weighed down by that so if I can
ask you guys one thing it's not what
your favorite Robin Williams movie is is
not to comment below and in the comment
section is to circulate this video get
it around put it on your Twitter put it
on your Facebook I want to donate a lot
of money to this cause maybe we can all
just make a difference today but as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more